what's the name of earth's largest moon
wait a minute what's the name do we have
more than one is there a scientific name
[Music]
hello everyone my name is freddy and i'm
here with the stars of abc's newest
sitcom abbott elementary elementary avid
elementary how are we feeling great
we're happy i love the excitement
because i'm actually here to test you
all elementary school knowledge and that
should be pretty easy to play teachers
on tv i mean the staff here is
incredible they're all amazing teachers
you'll be playing for a chance to win 10
000
and that money will go towards teachers
across the country
here are the rules you have 30 seconds
to answer there are 25 questions every
question you get correct that's money in
the bank every question you get
incorrect that money is gone give me the
question
all right quinta you're up first grade
history who was not
one of the founding fathers benjamin
franklin thomas jefferson aaron burr
alexander hamilton you got this freddy
my answer is a benjamin franklin
unfortunately that's incorrect
i don't want y'all to judge me on this
the show is really i'm good at writing
tv
the store has ten potatoes and you take
away two of them how many potatoes left
i don't like potatoes
what is the value of pie one three one
four
no three one four
three point
one four five
it's two isn't it it's two two i knew it
was two
it was five i don't trust myself write
this fraction as a decimal
the fraction the fraction is
1 4.25
yes
[Applause]
whose face is on the penny i would like
to say abraham lincoln final answer yeah
yes
and you are correct oh my god
so this one actually requires a visual
aid name this state i was just there
idaho oh that would be um idaho you are
correct yes
look at you
nice to meet you ryan it's gregory and
let's see how long you'll be here
then i'll remember your name okay tim
this historical figure is most known for
her work in the underground
ruth bader railroad
and harriet tubman and you are carmen
[Applause]
which geometrical shape has no vertices
has
okay so we only have the science
category left let's finish off strong i
believe in you guys i think this is
going to be great saturn's largest moon
is called titan what's the name of
earth's largest moon we just call it the
moon
it's just moon i'm gonna call it luna
okay well titan is like a greek thing or
i don't know do you have a final answer
luna incorrect it's the moon
[Applause]
we met the moon we just gave it a
separate nickname yes luna is moon in
latin and i love and i love the way
you're thinking about this so i'm gonna
go ahead and give you this 500 yes
yo my father was a nasa physicist and he
is so ashamed of me right now
all right y'all this is the last one
and it's on quinta what is moving air
called
breeze no
[Applause]
i have to say this was such a blast do
you want to find out how much you won
desperately actually raised 8 600
dollars for teachers across the country
we love teachers here just like avid
elementary so we're going to go ahead
and give you the full 10 000 views
thanks for having us thank y'all so much
for being here and playing with me and
thank you all so much for watching be
sure to check out the special premiere
of abbott elementary streaming right now
on hulu and catch all new episodes
starting tuesday on abc
[Music]